we're back with the greatest panel ever
put together on tv and it's not these
people
it's these people the pedal within
a panel yes so we've been on the air
for about five years now actually a half
an hour and the time has really flown
and i thought what a great time to ask
some expert judges
about how i'm doing so far joining us to
weigh in
america's newsroom co-anchor and the
five co-host dana perino the host of the
uh tucker carlson tonight show and
tucker carlson today
on fox nation tucker carlson
oh wait you so bill hammer couldn't make
it
all right uh fox and friends co-host
brian kilmeade
all right um i want you guys to be
honest you've watched uh more than a few
blocks at this show dana
um i know it's pretty late for you to be
up um
what did you make of it so far well
first of all you just stole my first
joke
because i can't believe that i stayed up
three hours past my bedtime to watch
this
yes you might consider moving this show
back to 3 a.m and where you belong and
maybe
you know post it on youtube or something
that was actually quite successful the
old red eye
also i wore orange to match your
logo and i realize now that you seem to
have stolen it from
garfield the cat and now the legal
department has already called you're 25
minutes into your first show and we
already have our first lawsuit
so let me say i brought down some uh
some
two for charisma oh thank you out of two
out of ten two for preparation
two for delivery how did i come up with
that number
i don't know because 2 is your suicide
wow hi dana although i also have to say
i was very
impressed that kaylee mcaney knows less
about illegal drugs than i do
and i salute you for that
wow that hurt all right tucker uh well
um what do you think so far of this show
wow on fox don't mess with dana perino
but sharp um look it's your first show i
don't want to be you know i don't want
to be critical i want to highlight the
positives i think there are some
there are some more points too but i
would i just want to start with
something that
almost nobody ever acknowledges which is
your studio audience
and unlike a lot of studio audiences
they're not hyenas
no i'm serious there's not a lot of
forced
defying you know there's a lot of
restraint there's some tittering
there's some like chuckling you know
what i mean yes and so for that
for the kind of realistic nature of
their responses
i give them a 10. you go studio audience
so i also want to compliment cat tim um
for the revelatory nature of her
participation she just admitted on
television and the host missed it
somehow
but that she's free-based parmesan
cheese no i did not now even in a moment
where everyone's admitting
i think he did not you know nobody kind
of holds back
too much parmesan cheese but to admit
that you've smoked parmesan cheese
through a crack pipe
you go cat tim i want to party with you
as
to the question i know you're i know
you're asking and you're like well what
about the guy whose name is on the show
the anchor as it were i just want to say
it i'm not being critical at all i like
the exclamation point
i think it's emphatic it's bold it's
vigorous
and i'm just speaking particularly of
that punctuation mark and and i want to
affirm it with another one
okay and i'll stop there
i have not smoked parmesan cheese catnip
is another story and that was an
accident um
so uh mr kilmeade what are your thoughts
on this show
well i'm not gonna stoop to giving
numbers uh
i am not i don't have a figure skating
background i've not been into gymnastics
international competitions but i'll say
this
there's a little bit too much you i
thought it would be more about the panel
i wish there wasn't such emphasis on you
and my problem was i had such high hopes
for the show i think
i went up to you last week and i said
greg you're going to do great and then i
watched it
and i'm thinking to myself what was i
thinking
there's one thing i noticed about late
night television is they don't criticize
each other anymore
colbert goes on each other's show they
go and host each other award shows
and within three minutes you alienated
jimmy fallon stephen colbert uh the guy
from the daily show i forgot his name
then you alienated delta coke baseball
brian williams cnn
so every late night host you're supposed
to be the unifier bring america together
i see an a-plus panel i see a very
handsome audience
you're right a legitimate audience no
legitimate laugh track
and then i see you greg and i'm saying
to myself is there going to be a guest
host let's say you get
injured or you run a fever because
everything's there the set is there
i just don't hear the questions the
punctuation the humor the smile the
outfit
it all just below average and i wish it
could be different wow
i mean yes